hi
um
I'd like to talk about I always tend to
be very dubious about talking about uh
being enlightened and
what I call spiritual stuff
of course there must be other words to
talk about
why is spiritual stuff well to me it's
not religion
but it feels very close to what one
would feel like if they were very
religious
I'll bounce around a lot so I hope I'm
going to make sense here
if a person is deep within their
religion beliefs
they will think that their particular
God or Allah
is listening to them
is helping them watch over them
but it's as if you know they're talking
or
connecting with a
another entity another being
to me being enlightened
I'd put this on the a similar
platform thinking
let me try to give you some ideas I was
brought up a Catholic
and didn't like it I felt as if it was a
forced religion
but I have experienced unusual things
while being in the church
and
and it wasn't in the Catholic Church
even though I was brought up in the
Catholic school with the church being
next to the school and having to
go into the church
or times and I wish to remember
but I had more I think
unusual experiences in in other churches
with other religions
with other faiths
I've had some very nice warm feelings
in when I've been in a mosque
I've been in two different ones now
I've had a very nice uh it's a sort of a
warm feeling it's like a blanket of warm
air comes over you and you feel part of
that warm air
a new question
whether you are actually
solid or not they say we're not solid
but that that's for another scientific
time of thinking and talking
another time was when I went to listen
to a speaker
who was of the Christian faced
um
the the uh I don't know what they call
it the Protestants
but anyhow I went to listen to a speaker
in a in a theater
and I had the same feeling that um I was
the only one in the whole theater
and the warmth that came over me again
and it was if I was in
some kind of Trance some kind of
warm comfortable place where
where myself
and the person speaking the words
but connected in a time lapse
but it was such a joyous time lapse
I wasn't
I not able to come out of here but not
wishing to come out of it because it was
such a nice place to be within a Feeling
it's as if you go to higher thinking a
higher place within
within what you are as a natural
human being who am I sitting in front of
this camera talking to you
and trying to explain
why I felt
you possibly most of you anyhow possibly
well
not have a clue what I'm talking about
then others may have touched upon it
this
wall failing
it's like an air blanket
but is not just a warm breeze blowing at
you
but you are part of that warmth
I could even describe it like an intense
love
of
um not being of this Earth
that you would normally feel
like I'm sitting in a chair now
and I can feel the base underneath my
back side
I can throw the arms of the chair on my
elbows resting on
but when you're in this what I call this
warmth blanket when you're
in another mind state
you don't feel anything apart from your
mind is completely immersed in a
wonderful
I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna say a place
of happiness and love
far greater than
what you can normally
feel
anybody who's found love will know that
the depth of love comes from
yourself and it and it radiates out and
it's a feeling a sensing it's not
something you can describe to another
who has never felt it
this um
I believe could come close to somebody
if you've ever been on drugs or any
description
people have said to me
oh I know what you're saying when I've
talked to them about it oh I know what
you're saying when I was uh
hallucinating
I had an out-of-body experience just
like you're talking about
others would say oh yes I know what you
mean
I've been on the ceiling looking down
upon the people and in the room
so I don't know if this is something
that we trigger within ourself
whether it's something we we don't know
how to activate
in the case of the people who take the
drugs this is perhaps their way of
activating it
but is it real if it's under
a drug situation
but why
my
times when I've had this
I've never been under drugs or the
influence of drink or anything else it's
been as clear as I'm sitting here now
it's just that something has taken my
mind and I've been immersed in it
to me
it's as close as one will get to being
enlightened
I
will talk more about it in my next film
and if you're interested in it please
listen
I can't help you in any way on how to
experience it
because I don't know how I
activated this experience myself
all I know is
happened to me several times in my life
I don't remember it until I was in my
late 20s and it seemed to then activate
itself and since then I've had several
experiences
and even though I can be quite I may not
come across this but quite depressed in
myself as a person because I appeared to
be a deep thinker
I've looked at um and because I every
day wake up and think about
my martial art of Aikido
because that seems to have triggered
many things that have allowed me to see
these extra things and and absorb these
extra
elements that the mind and body can take
and see and do
sense
to me I'm grateful that it's unlocked
that because of perhaps it was fate and
I would have unlocked these experiences
anyhow
I can't say that it wasn't Aikido that
took me to the theater to see the
the religious person speaking it was
somebody who was very deep in religion
and trying to what I call Bible bash me
into
also wanted to find God
um another person has taken me to mosque
really just to see
the surroundings I don't know if their
intentions are that I should
start reading the Quran and
finding our love or I don't know what
their intent is all I know is that I've
had similar experiences in all different
places but they've all been under the
banner of religion religion
and my biggest experience was following
a lady called mother mirror in Frankfurt
Frankfurt Germany and that was my
biggest experience of being
of
touching the the enlightenment the Age
of Enlightenment Enlightenment I don't
know and that's what I talk about in my
next film
I hope you found this of some interest
but I know he's a minority subject
people like to hear about rather than a
majority
barking Army give you
this in hopes that it may help someone
who questions what they
appear to flash in and out of in their
lifetime thank you for your time and
your ears